- Good evening, everyone.
I'm Noel Lenski.
I teach classics and history here at Yale,
and I am charged with the
honor and the pleasure
of introducing our
speaker for this evening,
Professor Clifford Ando of
the University of Chicago.
I'd just like to begin
with a few words, however,
about the namesake of our event,
Michael Ivanovich Rostovtzeff.
Tomorrow, the 10th of November,
will mark the 154th anniversary
of Rostovtzeff's birth in Zhytomyr,
in what is today southwestern Ukraine,
about 140 kilometers west of Kyiv,
therefore, a place troubled
greatly by violence
inflicted by the state of Russia,
a state in which Rostovtzeff grew up
and, in fact, was
educated under the Czars.
He studied classics and ancient history
at Kyiv and St. Petersburg,
where he went on to serve
as professor of Latin
for 20 years down to 1918.
In the upheaval of the Russian Revolution,
Rostovtzeff, who opposed the Bolsheviks,
was forced to flee Russia,
and eventually landed in
Madison, Wisconsin in 1920.
After teaching there for five years,
he moved to New Haven to take
up a professorship at Yale,
and remained there down
to his retirement in 1944.
He lived on until 1952, when
he passed away in New Haven,
and is now buried in the
Grove Street Cemetery
where a group of us went today
to lay a wreath on his tomb.
Rostovtzeff was a brilliant scholar
who revolutionized the
study of the ancient world
in ways that have only
really come into clear focus
in contemporary America,
the contemporary world at the moment.
He combined an interest in archeology
and in archeological field work
with a passion for economic
and cultural history.
His two greatest works,
"The Social and Economic
History of the Roman Empire,"
published first in 1926,
and "The Social and Economic History
of the Hellenistic
World", published in 1941,
were both gold mines of information
produced well before the
information revolution.
A voracious reader of countless languages
and an avid aficionado
of quantitative methods,
he set the benchmark
for source-based historical investigations
in the second quarter of the 20th century.
Rostovtzeff published some 12 monographs
and countless articles
displaying a breathtaking
knowledge of ancient history,
from early Greece through late Rome,
and from Africa to Gaul, to
Egypt, to the Crimea, to Syria.
It was his field work
that uncovered the fortress
city of Dura-Europos,
parts of which are now on display
in the Yale University Art Gallery.
Although his methods fell out of favor
in the mid-20th century,
in large part due to
the unmistakable imprint
left by his bitter experience
of the Russian Revolution
on his scholarly views,
Rostovtzeff's taste for big data
and for the intermingling of
textual and material evidence
have come roaring back in
the scholarly presence.
In addition to his scholarly works,
his excavation finds and his
methodological innovations,
Rostovtzeff continues to impact
Yale's intellectual environment
through this lecture series.
The annual Michael Rostovtzeff
lecture and colloquium
was made possible through
a bequest by his widow,
the late Sophie Kulczycki Rostovtzeff.
For the last 16 years,
we've been able to welcome
some of the most distinguished researchers
in the field of ancient history
as lecturers in the series,
and to sponsor a symposium
the following morning
including equally distinguished scholars
to comment on the lecture
and engage in learned
dialogue with the lecturer.
So that will occur tomorrow morning,
beginning at 9:00 AM in Phelps Hall 401.
Our speaker this evening, Clifford Ando,
is the David B. and Clara F. Stern
distinguished service professor.
He's professor of classics and history
at the University of Chicago,
where he is chair and has
been for the last six years.
Ando studied at Princeton University
and then at the University of Michigan,
where he completed his PhD in 1996.
He's the editor of the monographic series,
"Empire and After,"
with the University of Pennsylvania Press,
senior editor of the Bryn
Mawr Classical Review,
editor of "KNOW: A Journal on
the Formation of Knowledge,"
and is on the editorial
board of seven other journals
or monographic series.
He has held visiting professorships
or temporary appointments
at 14 universities
across the United States,
Europe, and New Zealand.
He has held numerous fellowships,
including the ACLS Burkhardt Fellowship,
and currently, an NEH Scholarly Editions
and Translations grant
for his project on Roman statutes,
which, I believe, is the source
for some of what he'll
talk about this evening.
Ando is the author of seven monographs,
including "Imperial Ideology
and Provincial Loyalty
in the Roman Empire,"
published with the University
of California Press in 2000,
which won the Charles Goodwin
Award of Merit in 2003
from the then American
Philological Association.
He's the editor of 14 books,
including "The Oxford Handbook
of Roman Law and Society,"
and the first volume of the forthcoming
"Cambridge World History of Rights,"
which will appear next year.
He's published over 120
articles and 60 reviews
and short notes.
He is, in brief, boundless in energy,
but also in range and in brilliance.
Just as to range,
Ando covers in his published research
fields as diverse as the Roman Republic,
Roman imperial history, late antiquity,
Latin and Greek literature,
the history of law,
the history of religion,
the history of philosophy,
and the philosophy of law,
the philosophy of language,
and the history of knowledge.
And I could go on.
His work has had a major
impact on the field
in at least four respects.
First and foremost, Ando
has played a crucial role,
arguably the crucial role,
in bringing classics and ancient history
into dialogue with philosophy,
particularly the philosophy of mind,
epistemology, and phenomenology.
This was clear already
in his first monograph,
which covered a remarkable range of time
and breadth of sources,
and situated these into
a sociological framework
constructed especially
around the Frankfurt School
and his theory of law and
reason within the life world.
Second, Ando has helped make
classics and ancient history
a serious interlocutor with
scholars of law and government.
His recent work on citizenship
in the ancient world,
particularly in the Roman world,
has helped us to rethink
our contemporary world,
where questions of citizenship
and state belonging
are deeply relevant and deeply implicated
in discourses of inclusion and exclusion.
Third, Ando's serious work on language,
not just at the level of philology,
a field in which he is expert,
but more importantly,
in the realm of philosophy of language,
have helped us to comprehend the way
in which linguistic habits and practices
shape the way that we think and reason,
and thus, the way that we shape our world.
But finally, his work as
a coordinator of people,
of ideas, of information,
make him a hub around which
so much that is happening
in ancient history, legal
history, and intellectual history
is turning at the moment.
The project on Roman
statutes, for example,
seeks to bring together all
the evidence that we have
for positive law in the Republic
and early imperial periods,
a task as gargantuan as it is frustrating,
given the tantalizing
but fragmentary nature of the material.
I think it's fair to say
that there is no other
scholar working today
with the breadth of
expertise and connections
to make this project work.
Without Clifford Ando in our world,
the study of ancient
history, of antiquity,
of the history of
knowledge and of religion
would be greatly impoverished,
which is why it brings me
great pleasure this evening
to be able to offer
you a chance to partake
in the riches that he has to offer,
to enjoy the learning and
the breadth of knowledge
that Professor Ando can bring to us.
And so, without further ado,
I would ask us all to join
in welcoming Clifford Ando
to speak to us tonight on the subject of
"Empire's Law: The Roman State
in the Second Century BCE."
(all applaud)
- So thank you, Noel, for that
quite amazing introduction.
So I'm gonna try to be disciplined today,
'cause I realized that a
version of this lecture
was sent to the people
who are gonna lead the
conversation tomorrow.
And I'm gonna have to
suppress my natural urge
just to, like, run off and improvise,
because I think it's most fair
to the people who've actually
already read the text
and are gonna be responding to the text
that they have received
to adhere closely to the document.
I'll try to be good in a
way that I'm often not.
So I want to start also, in
addition to thanking Noel,
to thank the Department of Classics
for this extraordinary invitation.
I spent a great deal of
time in graduate school
reading the prestige
works of ancient history,
the way you will as a kind
of person entering a field.
So I spent a great deal of time
reading Simon, Brunt, and Miller,
and then Hopkins, or Finley
and Hopkins, I should say.
And then, you know, Eck,
and Nicolet, and so on,
all of whom have something like
a substantial and legible pedigree
worthwhile reflecting on at this moment
because the chairs of
the Roman history chair in Oxford
and the chair of ancient
history at Cambridge
are vacant at the same time,
I think for the first time ever.
And I also spent a lot of time
reading Rostovtzeff and MacMullen,
who did not, so far as I could tell,
as far as I could piece them together,
have a pedigree that I could understand.
I couldn't understand
their educational histories
or why they wrote what they wrote
in a way that is sort
of intelligible to me
why the other people did what they did.
I worked on the past on
topics that align closely
with central themes in Rostovtzeff's work.
Today's lecture, I confess, does not,
but I want to pay tribute, as I begin,
to the quite extraordinary
sequence of ancient historians
who've taught here.
And that includes not simply Rostovtzeff
and Ramsay MacMullen, whom I miss.
I've spent a lot of time in
sitting in the Atticus Cafe
being told by Ramsay something like,
"Well, you get everything wrong."
(audience laughs)
When you,
almost all conversations
begin with something like
Ramsay remarking on a
paper I'd recently sent in
by saying something like,
"Cliff, when you say 'X,'"
or frequently, he'd say,
"When you say, 'The Romans say,'
I wanna know which Romans."
And then...
(audience laughs)
I'm sure many of you had
conversations like this
with Ramsay McMullen.
And, of course, also John
Matthews and Noel himself,
who also works in many
fields of ancient history
and, I think, brings a distinct respect
both for evidence and method
to all the fields in which he works.
Oh, wait.
I think I have to move the cursor.
(gasps) There we go.
How exciting.
So what I'm going to do today
is start by talking a
little bit about some,
I think, characteristic myths
that undergird the study of Roman law.
In a written version of this,
I talk about more of them,
if only because
sometimes taking out a
kind of a truism of a field
and holding it up to the light is,
well, I mean, if you're a
nerd, kind of hilarious.
Especially people outside
the field of Roman law
could well ask themselves, you know,
as a kind of anthropological matter,
did you realize you were in a university
with people who believe
this sort of thing?
And then I'm gonna spend
a little bit of time,
as you will in any ancient history talk,
in making a set of empirical claims
about what evidence we
actually have for something.
And then I'm going to
talk about the moment
when something like the
vernacular narrative,
which I'm going to try to
disprove, came into being,
and talk briefly about
why people believe what
they do about Roman law,
before, in the end, making a
whole bunch of bravura claims
about what actually happened
in the second century Republic,
which, as I was remarking to Seth,
are, up to a point, disconnected
from my empirical claims,
and have the great
virtue by being so broad,
as broad as they are,
of being, I think, probably not provable,
but not falsifiable either,
which is a, you know, a
good thing for a lecture.
So let me just start, then,
by talking briefly about
what I take to be two discrete myths
that undergird vernacular
histories of Roman law.
The first, the Romans produced
complex written statutes
in a continuous tradition
from at least 510 BCE,
and second, prior to the development
of the so-called formulary system,
the civil law was
administered by pontiffs,
but probably also by magistrates,
positive law rested on the Twelve Tables,
but procedure had been specified
by subsequent statutes,
except that these
statutes seems themselves
to have been laid out,
to have laid out the positive
law that they regulated.
I'll take these in turn.
First, regarding the history
of Roman legislation,
there have been several
attempts to catalog,
mostly from Livy,
Roman laws chronologically,
of which the most
influential modern effort
is that by Giovanni Rotondi.
After a simply phenomenal
and extended introduction
that covers all aspects of
the production of legislation,
Rotondi offers lists of
statutes according to genre,
as here, section two,
laws de provocazione,
followed by a catalog
that provides for each
item, ancient testimonia,
a quick summary of the
law's supposed content,
followed by references to research tools
on matters of detail and context.
The format of the modern
catalog by Marianne Elster
is very similar,
albeit her representation
of the data is much fuller.
It's in that sense that Elster's work
is much closer to a standalone resource.
To give you some idea of
the scale of the enterprise
as it is mapped by these
modern research tools,
Marianne Elster catalogs 231 laws
of the so-called middle Republic alone,
from 366 to 134 BCE.
The tiny print's not a
deliberate act of ambiguation.
None of this data is
relevant to what will follow,
except in if you were writing
some sort of history of the Roman novel.
We'll get back to that.
Second, regarding the
history of Roman civil law,
in the first chapters of book
four of his "Institutes,"
Gaius offers a brief idiosyncratic history
of some aspects of Roman procedure.
In particular, Gaius
describes five legal actions
that he terms "legislaciones,"
statutory actions,
as follows.
"The actions that the ancients had in use
were called statutory actions,
either because they were
created by statutes,
since, of course, the
edicts of the praetor,
by which many actions had been introduced,
were not yet in use,
or because they were framed in the words
of the statutes themselves
and were therefore treated as immutable,
even as the statutes were.
Whence it was held that a man who,
when suing for the
cutting down of his vines,
used the word 'vines' in his claim,
lost his case, because he
ought to have said 'trees,'
seeing that the law of the Twelve Tables,
on which his action for
cutting down his vines lay,
spoke of cutting down trees in general."
Now Gaius is more or less our only source
for pre-formulary procedure,
and his account is as
partial as it is tantalizing.
It's a cautionary tale
about both our knowledge,
but also their knowledge of law
before the second century BCE,
that we know next to nothing about the law
that principally affected the change
from the statutory actions
to the formulary procedure.
I refer to what the Romans
called the lex Aebutia,
date unknown,
about which Rotondi himself says,
"To this law is attributed
the introduction of formulary procedure,
but it is impossible to
determine its precise content
or its impact."
Now I will close,
I'll say more before I close
about the lex Aebutia
and the Twelve Tables,
but in brief, my claim
is that Gaius received
two traditions about early Roman law.
One concerned the Twelve Tables,
the other concerned the
so-called statutory actions.
What we'd witnessed in the
opening paragraphs of book four
is his attempt to allow for
both of these traditions
to be operative at the same time.
We should not believe either.
Instead, in order to understand
what the Romans were doing
when they invented themselves
as creatures of law,
we need to abandon our own longing
for knowledge that we cannot have,
which has induced a kind of credulity
that we would tolerate in
no other field of inquiry.
"We," meaning services,
especially historians of law,
not the good citizens of classics.
And examined instead the context
in which these Roman
speculations were made.
More on this theme as we go along.
And finally, before I turn
to the substance of my talk,
I want to pay tribute to what I think is
one of the greatest books of Roman history
of the 20th century,
namely, Arnold Toynbee's
"Hannibal's Legacy."
Today, if Toynbee is cited at all,
it is as an exemplar of error
in regard to the history
of land use in Italy,
but this was not a major
concern for Toynbee.
On the contrary,
his interest lay in the
form of the Roman state,
and his thesis, simply stated,
might be that Roman hegemony in Italy
prior to the first Punic war,
took a specific form,
distinctive both within
the ancient Mediterranean
and, indeed, within the
history of federal structures
known in the world at the time.
The wars with Carthage,
Rome's engagement with the
Hellenistic world more generally,
brought Rome into competition
with states of a very different form.
And in order to beat them,
and in consequence of defeating them,
Rome, itself, was transformed.
In short, power existing
in memetic relation
to that which it resists.
Through competition
with Hellenistic powers,
Rome itself became a Hellenistic kingdom.
And yet, it preserved both
public law structures in Italy
and republican forms of
politics domestically
that were increasingly at odds
with the scale of state power
and the political economics
of Mediterranean empire.
"Hannibal's Legacy" traces
the history of this dissonance
and its effects on myriad aspects
of Roman social and economic relations.
This is not the place to
assess Toynbee's achievement,
but I should like at the very least
to insist that one give
his argument its due.
It was not simple, nor was it falsifiable.
The conclusion of this paper
will try to take up the challenge
that he laid before the field.
So the evidence that
we have for Roman law,
part one, statute.
And Noel is of course completely correct
that I was inspired to this project
by essentially tracing out patterns
and reading, and rereading,
and rereading, and rereading
the corpus of epigraphically
preserved Roman laws.
Now is it, and I've
done that work for you,
so none of you has to.
(audience laughs)
So you're welcome.
It's a truism of scholarship
on Roman legal thought,
and on Roman culture more generally,
that the jurists were
like their compatriots
in having a deep respect for history.
I've written along these lines myself,
with a caveat that I've
argued that the jurists,
and Roman theorists more generally,
consistently assembled
historical data in order to argue
recent practice has precedence
over hoary antiquity.
That is why, as each successive
generation of jurists
wrote commentaries on
earlier commentaries,
on earlier commentaries,
it became unnecessary to
cite the words of statute.
Actions at law were available
in respect of statutes
based on recent acts of
application and interpretation,
and these were largely available
in contemporary language.
The contrast with Athens,
where the wording of the original statute
had to be cited in court,
could not be stronger
Despite this interpretive position
with regard to the Roman jurists
and their respect for the past,
even a conventional history
like that of Aldo Schiavone,
so everyone else insisted,
I mean, basically all of the scholars
think that Roman jurists
and the Romans in general
like to preserve the past.
It's something about mos
maiorum, crap like that.
And despite our insistence
that the Romans valued the past
and they valued precedent and so on,
even people like Aldo
Schiavone has to admit
that their knowledge of
academic legal writing
before the 90s BCE
was close to non-existent.
He says, "Despite," I'll
start with the second.
"Despite this," I'll
skip the first paragraph.
"Despite this tendency
of the whole course of
republican jurisprudence
until Quintus Mucius,
later jurors would preserve
only a vague and blurry memory.
In the body of legal literature
that survived to the present day,
the theses and doctrines of
authors prior to Quintus Mucius
are explicitly cited on no more
than about 15 occasions at all,
and very few of these references
suggest a direct reading
of the original texts."
My ambition today is to
reveal a similar pattern
with regard to knowledge
by persons in the second
century BCE of earlier law,
and then to pose some questions
about the conclusions we might draw
and the speculations we might make
on the basis of this pattern.
Now I've never read a book or an article
that reflects on the historical data
about the history of Roman legislation
that is contained within
the legislation itself,
but the writers of Roman laws
knew a lot about Roman law.
They understood that any
given piece of legislation
intervened in a landscape,
a social world that was regulated by
and conformed itself to prior legislation.
So for example, the first
extant Roman statute,
the lex repetundarum of
122 BCE cites three laws.
The lex Rubria is very
likely this statute of 122
that authorized the foundation
of the colony of Carthage
and is therefore Gracchan in date.
The lex Calpurnia is a law
on magisterial malfeasance
of 149 BCE,
and the lex Junia is unknown
outside two references to it in this text,
but the fact that it's cited
after the lex Calpurnia
strongly suggests that
it postdates that law.
In short, the lex repetundarum
cites no law earlier than 149 BCE.
The picture is similar
if we turn to the lex agraria of 111 BCE.
Beyond some generic
references to situations
that were created by prior
enactments of the people
in lines 15 and 29,
the lex agraria makes reference
to four named statutes.
Oop, yeah.
A lex Sempronia, a lex
Rubria, a lex Livia,
and a censorial law of
Lucius Caecilius Metellus
and Gnaeus Domitius Ahenobarbus.
The lex Sempronia de
agraria dates to 123 BCE,
namely, a law of Gaius Gracchus
that, in large measure, reactivated a law
of his brother Tiberius
from a decade earlier.
The lex Rubria on the
foundation of Carthage dates,
as we have seen, to 122 BCE.
The lex Livia is the law of 146 BCE
that appointed a senatorial commission
to assist Scipio Aemilianus
in the organization of Africa.
And Lucius Caecilius Metellus
and Gnaeus Domitius Ahenobarbus
were censors in 115 BCE.
In other words, the lex
agraria cites no statute
earlier than 146 BCE.
The pattern holds,
if one continues the
analysis in this form,
throughout the entire corpus
of existing Roman statutes.
I cannot promise that I
caught every citation,
but the ones relevant to this project
are probably that in the
lex de provinciis praetoriis
of 100 BCE,
referring to a law of Marcus
Porcius Cato of unknown date,
but almost, very, very
likely contemporaneous
with the law on praetorian
provinces itself,
and a citation of a so-called lex Laetoria
in the tablet of Heraclea.
Now, we have a number of later references
to something called the lex Laetoria.
A law of the same name
is cited by Plautus,
which seems anomalous.
The content of the lex Laetoria
cited in chapter 84 of
the Flavian municipal law
is so different,
that Michael Crawford has speculated
that the name used in the
tablet of Heraclea is a mistake.
Now. bracketing this problematic case,
the pattern in the totality of
subsequent legislation holds.
No certain reference is ever made
in an extant Roman legislation
to a statute passed before 149 BCE,
and no reference at all
can even implausibly be reconstructed
so as to refer to a
statute before 200 BCE.
You can probably tell where
I'm going with this argument.
My claim is going to be
that no one before the
1st century, give or take,
ever mentions a statute written
before the Hannibalic War.
Nor reports, of course,
if you don't cite it,
you can't report the
words of such a statute.
But let me proceed step by step.
The next genre of evidence I
want to take up is oratory.
Although I focus on reports about orators
of the second century BCE,
I should say a word about
the few reports we have
about earlier writers.
Substantively it makes
no difference to my case,
since the reported fragments
have almost nothing to do with law.
But in the sole case that does or might,
that is to say, this
fragment of Censorinus,
not only does 250 years separate the event
from its first so-called testimonial,
but the anecdote itself,
supposedly on the occasion
of his holding the censorship
for a second time, around 80 years of age,
is completely implausible.
That said, so I mean,
so I think it's clear that the
entire event is just made up.
That neither of the people,
neither Valerius Maximus nor Plutarch
knew anything about this.
But that isn't even important.
What is interesting is that
the elaboration of the legend
does illustrate a pattern
that interests me.
For what it's worth,
the story as it's related
by Valerius Maximus
reports only a speech before the people.
But two generations later,
the story had become one about public law,
hence, in Plutarch, right?
They voted, he passed a law.
The two testimonia thus illustrate
a pattern of very considerable
historical importance,
for all that the
testimonia amount to lies.
And they are lies.
It's clear neither Valerius Maximus
nor Plutarch had a reliable source.
They are not individually
drawing on a tradition
that reported a contio
and the passage of a law,
such that Valerius Maximus
selectively mentions the assembly
and Plutarch mentions the law,
the sorts of arguments that people make
using shitty evidence like this.
On the contrary, the Romans
came to want to see themselves
as a people whose life had been
regulated by law ab initio.
And in each retelling,
the past came to resemble the
story that the Romans needed.
Why this occurred and when it occurred
is an important historical explanandum.
Now allow me to be precise
about what I'm arguing
about the evidence of the second century.
It is not that political oratory
did not discuss matters of law.
The fragments of the
second century orators
frequently concern legislation,
but none of the orators is represented,
none of them is ever represented, I think,
as arguing for or against
the passage of a law,
or, for that matter,
arguing for or against a
particular political decision
or for or against any policy decision
by means of the citation of
archaic or republican law,
mid-republican law.
Indeed, none of them ever
names an historical statute,
let alone regards a contemporary problem
as potentially regulated by earlier law,
or even analogous to a situation
that might be potentially
regulated by earlier law.
It might be useful to situate this pattern
in respect of legal history
within a broader pattern
of both attitudes to
history and normativity
and within kind of ways
of talking about history
and normativity at the time.
I think this slide offers
the sum total of references to custom,
to one's betters or the
greaters, i.e., the maiores,
and the full roster of exemplary stories
in second century oratory
down to about 120.
Which is not to say the
later literature we have
does not attribute relevant usage
to texts of the second century BCE,
but when it's sort Jelius, for example,
that a second century orator
is made to speak of his betters,
I think we should be as
suspicious as when Jelius
caused Scipio Africanus
to use the term imperium
to refer to empire.
That is if other things about the,
in the case of Jelius,
when Jelius attributes to
people in the second century
language that is simply totally
implausible in one sentence,
I think we should be deeply suspicious
about the rest of the fragment.
There's more we could
discuss here, obviously.
Now, before I proceed with the rest of,
before I proceed to the
next part of the paper,
I wanna offer a caveat regarding evidence
I'm not gonna survey publicly,
to which I'm gonna append a caution
about the content of that evidence,
namely, the so-called fragments
of the Roman historians.
Now, it may well happen
that the content of one or
another fragment of an historian
is going to destabilize the
empirical basis of my project,
but I think some caution is in order here.
Very few fragments of the Roman historians
contain the actual words
of earlier writers.
More importantly, Romans
of nearly every period
wrote on the assumption of a
kind of homeomorphy over time
at the level of both practices
and institutional arrangements.
This was part of the
point of writing history
in the form of lists, like Fosti.
They both organized memory
and they asserted a kind
of unspoken continuity
in institutional operations.
What is taken for granted
when we say that we have
always elected consuls
and, indeed, that we know who they are?
Roman historians were
therefore not historicist.
Their intuitions will have
been to assume continuity
along more axes of social
practice than we would do.
In consequence, Roman historians
cite earlier historians
largely as it regards points
of agreement or disagreement
on matters of detail,
because each generation is
taken by later generations
to have inhabited the
same Rome as they did,
and their narratives are
represented in their texts
are paraphrased on this assumption.
If a historian of the late Republic
or an Augustan historian
cites an earlier analyst
as if that person narrated Roman history
as a history of laws,
one's gonna have to be
very careful, I think,
in assessing how much
agreement, and of what kind,
in regarding what matters
is being asserted by that citation.
Finally, it matters to the
broader claim I'm making
that historians in the ancient world
were generally not conditioned
to see absence as evidence.
In reading their predecessors,
they will have been triggered by patterns
other than those that
demand our attention.
But we are not they,
and so we are free to ask,
I think we are called upon to ask,
whether the absence of evidence
in this particular case
is evidence of something.
What does it reveal?
And what is entailed by our
answer to that question?
So far as I can tell,
no writer in the second century
BCE found it useful to cite
or even to refer to written legislation
that originated prior to
the second century BCE.
Despite this silence on the
part of authors, jurists,
and orators for the duration
of the second century,
the fulsome catalogs
of earlier legislation
that one can compile
from later literature,
from Cicero, Livy, and so on,
demand that we believe
something like the following.
Throughout the second century BCE,
secure data regarding the long
history of Roman legislation
was available and reliable.
It simply went uncited by anyone,
but was accurately preserved.
And then it was recovered
in the age of Sulla,
or whenever it was that
we begin to see it cited.
And when this, whenever this occurred,
the historical data were
reported in a fulsome
and disinterested fashion.
This picture of the
transmission of knowledge
is exactly as plausible as the
data that Augustus recovered
when he himself did research,
(audience laughs)
and read the speech of
Metellus Macedonicus
on the duty to produce children,
or found linen books in
the recesses of temples
containing rules on the
celebration of triumphs.
I'll say a bit more about
these kind of episodes
in Roman scholarship later.
Now, a minimalist conclusion
that we might draw
from the patterned silence in our sources,
to wit, from the absence
of evidence for earlier law
during the second century BCE,
is that no written legislation survived
from the earlier period
into the second century.
And this is why titles are
known in the first century,
but, more or less, no language.
For my part, I urge a maximalist position.
Written legislation from before 200 BCE
was not known in the second century
because it never existed
in the first place.
Institutions of communal
decision making surely existed.
The assembly made decisions,
but these were, by and
large, not written down.
Now, it would take some time to lay out
all the grounds for
skepticism that one might cite
regarding the knowledge
that the Romans had
of their own past.
And I should stress, you know,
that lots and lots of people
have written beautifully
and at length about the
reasons to be skeptical
about the history of the
early and middle Republic,
and at some level the
field oscillates over time
in 20 or 25 year increments
about just how much credulity
we extend to this information.
I'm not the first person
to compile these passages.
So I should add, right, I should insist
all modern historians are
aware of the extent to which
their sources have been
exposed as chimerical.
I think we just oscillate
in our unwillingness
to draw the conclusions
that our methods demand.
So let me cite only the
most famous cautions
offered to us by the ancients themselves.
I commence with Cicero's "Brutus,"
discussing the legends
invented and rehearsed
within aristocratic houses.
"And yet these eulogies
have made the record of Rome's
history more unreliable,
since they include many
things that did not happen.
False triumphs, exaggerated
numbers of consulships,
even false genealogies and
transfers to the plebs,
merging people of lower standing
with another family of the same name,
as though I were to claim
descent from the Manius Tullius
who was a patrician consul
with Servius Sulpicius
in the 10th year after the
expulsion of the kings."
When I say, "the legends
invented and rehearsed
within aristocratic houses,"
I mean, of course,
something like the
totality of raw material
available to the historical
tradition as they understood it.
Alongside this, one might
cite Livy's digression
on the reliability of
evidence available to him,
which runs along very similar lines
as he confronted problematic data
in the history of the Samnite Wars.
"Nor is it easy to prefer one narrative
or one authority over another.
Historical memory has been
contaminated, I think,
by funeral orations
and lying inscriptions
beneath portrait busts
as every family through deceitful lying
appropriates to itself high offices
and noteworthy achievements.
Certainly it's from this cause
that the deeds of individuals
and records of public actions
have been confused.
Nor does any writer survive
who is contemporary with these times
on whom one might reasonably
rely as a reliable source."
General statements like these
should be read alongside
Livy's repeated cautions
that even in regard to second
century events and personages,
the accounts and evidence available to him
were in radical disagreement.
And we're now talking about
Livy on the second century.
This is not Livy on some
episode in hoary antiquity.
"Many other things concerning
particularly the end of Scipio's life,
his trial, his death, funeral, and tomb
pull in opposite directions,
so that I do not know which report
or which writer I should follow.
There is no agreement as the accuser.
Some write that Marcus Naevius,
others that the Petillii accused him.
There's no agreement about the
timing, nor about the trial,
nor about the year when he died,
nor about where he died
or where he was buried.
Some say he died and was buried at Rome,
others at Liternum.
In both places, monuments
and statues are on display."
This isn't the effing body of Orestes.
(all laugh)
This is a person who lived
in real historical time,
and they haven't got a
clue where his body is.
Livy is similarly at a loss
regarding the death of Claudius Marcellus,
where he follows Coelius
Antipater at least far enough
to say that the account
left by Marcellus' own son,
who is an eyewitness
to his father's death,
was implausible.
(audience laughs)
Frankly, may be true, but.
But perhaps the most important
such remark on Livy's part
concerns the supposed
prosecution of Africanus
for which Livy had the evidence
of a fake speech attributed to Africanus
and a fake speech attributed to Gracchus.
"Nor is the disagreement only
among writers of history.
The speeches too,
if they are in fact what
they are said to be,
namely, those of Publius
Scipio and Tiberius Gracchus,
are inconsistent with each other.
The title of the speech of Publius Scipio
has the name of Marcus Naevius
the tribune as accuser.
The speech itself is without
the name of the accuser.
Now it calls him a
scoundrel, now a trifler.
Nor does even Gracchus'
speech make any mention at all
of the Petilii as accusers of Africanus
or of the prosecution," blah, blah, blah.
"An entirely different
story must be put together,
consistent with Gracchus' speech,
and those writers must
be followed," and so on.
In other words, the extant
speeches are taken by Livy
as serious evidence
despite having no plausible authenticity.
The speech of Gracchus, I
think, is clearly a declamation.
But Livy then tells you that he accepts it
as the plausible document
among this array,
and he allows that it's
going to be the north star
that shapes how he writes
his narrative of the event.
Regarding the specific
lessons we might draw
from these remarks and
others in this vein,
I can do no better than
quote the reprimand
that Fergus Miller offered
to mid-republican historians
a generation ago.
I look out at republican historians
feeling like I'm just
doing what Miller did.
I'm like, I wandered into
republican history from the empire
and I'm saying stupid stuff.
But I'm gonna read out
what Fergus said anyhow.
"We tend to insist not
only on knowing too much,
but on knowing precisely those things
which the ancient sources
themselves in their better moments
warn us that we cannot know.
That is to say, the attribution
to dateable individuals
of particular actions and achievements
and the grouping of individuals
into supposedly reliable family trees.
Now, regarding what I have
termed "their sources,"
in quotes,
we must always remember
that the Romans saw fit to
build a standard set of fosti,
a continuous record of
holders of high office,
only in the last decade
or so of the Republic.
The infrastructure to date things
even in the most rudimentary terms,
which perforce amounted to the data
by which laws might be
named and placed in time,
because of the way the Romans named laws,
did not exist in vernacular form
until after Cicero wrote "De re Publica."
Because as Cicero wrote "De re Publica,"
he was still writing to Atticus
to verify consular dates
about events in that work,
as also in the "Brutus."
The existence of a
complete list of consuls
was more than a condition of possibility
for the form of the state
that the Romans claim for themselves
and the kind of narrative
through which they told their story.
There.
Ah, that's weird.
It changed on the one screen
before it changed on the other.
The fleshing out of piecemeal knowledge
by the attribution of fictive consulates
to the same gentes over and over again
is frankly why we have laws
in duplicate or triplicate,
right?
It is emphatically not true
that the Valerii had a fondness for,
were, quote unquote, "known for,"
sponsoring laws de provocatione,
which is the sort of bullshit
you're frequently told in Roman histories.
In the literature, the
existence of the laws
is taken to establish an association
between the family and the cause,
which association is then
cited in pure circularity
to defend the reality of any one law.
But this is completely ridiculous.
The laws were
straightforwardly a byproduct
of the invention of the fosti.
Once you actually wrote down the fosti,
in something like the 40s BCE, right?
And there is no evidence that
they had any written record
of any fosti before the
second century BCE, right?
Once these were,
once you populated your
made up list with Valerii,
the answer to the question,
"Which Valerius was it that proposed
a lex Valeria de
provocatione?" was obvious.
Each of them did.
Now, it's precisely for this reason
that it was during the lifetime
of Cicero, or just before,
that we begin to see
inklings of the legal culture
that will flourish thereafter.
Commencing, perhaps,
from the age of Numantia,
narratives begin to appear
of the middle Republic
that contain doublets of later events.
Meaning that a past was being invented,
or at least was then being narrated
in such a way that the language and norms
relevant to some contemporary issue
were being discovered in the past,
which thereby became available
as norm in the present.
A treaty made in usu
populi is not binding.
(speaking Latin)
and all these kind of things
in contemporary language
that are then attributed to
people of the mid-Republic.
This material aggregates
in an accelerating way
and is finally granted
unassailable prestige
and normative power
when Augustus discovered,
in the so-called republican
constitutionalism,
by which I mean late, late, late,
late republican constitutionalism,
the foundations of monarchy.
It was during the reign of
Augustus and not earlier
that parties on all sides
seized on public law
as the lens through
which to construct a past
that was continuous with the present,
we were always already
a polity ordered by law,
by way of establishing a
new language of politics
for the age of republican monarchy.
The debates that issued in the misnamed
lex de imperio Vespasiani
and the records that are preserved,
the records of votes that are preserved
in the commentary of the Arval Brethren
are the best evidence of this.
The same might be said of
these researchers of Augustus
that I cited earlier.
That is to say,
his claim that he discovered a speech
of the censor Quintus Caecilius Metellus
on the duty to marry and bear children.
Now, before I make some
concluding remarks,
a word is in order
about the Twelve Tables.
The one early law whose words,
or, I should say, some of whose words,
Romans of the first
century BCE claim to know.
Now, I'm skeptical.
For one thing, as we've seen,
several Romans tell us
that their own knowledge
of events before the Hannibalic War
were deeply insecure.
And all Romans repeatedly
demonstrate the truth of this
through sheer not citing,
and apparently not even knowing,
any words of any document
outside of treaties
from the first 500 years of the Republic,
except for the Twelve Tables.
Which, as a preview for tomorrow,
Seth told me I may be
wrong about this, but,
(audience laughs)
which I think goes uncited
for at least 250 years
before suddenly,
deeply secure knowledge
of the Twelve Tables,
and no intervening
document, suddenly emerges.
Now, if there's an argument to be made
for the existence of the Twelve Tables,
it would have to center
on later narratives
of something like early
hermeneutic projects,
in particular, the
"Tripartita" of Sextus Aelius,
which might suggest that
something called the Twelve Tables
already existed or was
invented circa 200 BCE.
But if even this much
is true, Aelius failed,
because no author for
the next hundred years
cited either the Twelve Tables
or, for that matter, Aelius' own work.
Two remarkable scholarly projects
have been devoted to the
Twelve Tables in recent years.
The one led by Floreana Corsi
and the stunning edition
of Michel Humbert.
I don't wish rashly to
discount their work,
but I think we need more
than the testimony of Cicero
that the Tables was a necessarium carmen,
alongside, rather oddly,
a reference to the legislation
of Solon, of all things,
to prove that this was not in essence
a collective invention of many parties
of the late third century BCE,
if not, as I happen to think,
an invention of the age of Numantia.
So I conclude with remarks on,
quick remarks on three topics,
legal history, their
sciences of history and ours,
and the Roman state in
the second century BCE.
Now, regarding legal history,
no Roman statute,
nor practically any document
produced and authorized
by the institutional
machinery of the Roman state
survives in a contemporaneous copy
from before the end of the Hannibalic War.
Later Roman writers,
which is to say, Roman
writers writing much later,
say that such statutes existed,
but they cite neither the
language of such statutes,
nor do they provide a plausible account
of any institution of
knowledge transmission
that would explain how they
got their supposed knowledge.
I suggest to you they did not exist.
Virtually nothing, perhaps
in actuality nothing
of what the later literary sources say
about the history of law before
the Hannibalic War is true.
Certainly, there is no
evidence of any kind
that corroborates their claims,
nor any plausible evidence for a mechanism
by which knowledge was
preserved and passed down
to suggest how authors in
the later first century BCE
might have learned of such documents.
In believing them, we give
our credence to legend.
In support of this claim, I've
cited the writers of statute.
They were, themselves,
practitioners of a kind of legal history,
and they cite no law before 149 BCE
To put the matter another way,
I suggest to you that
the pattern of survival
regarding evidence for
written Roman statutes
is not happenstance.
Rather, the history,
our extant corpus of inscribed Roman laws,
reflects the actual history
of legislative enactment
fairly accurately.
In this light, what is
perhaps most stunning
about the later second century BCE
is how rapidly certain formal aspects
of the writing of law consolidate,
alongside intellectual resources
related to the predictable
use of written law.
Savings clauses, that is, you know,
places in a statute where you say,
"Nothing in this statute is taken
to contravene clause X
of this earlier statute,"
which is most of the
occasions when laws are cited
in the external legislation,
they take of the form of savings clauses.
Savings clauses are a
noteworthy case in point.
Conventional tools of
statutory interpretation
are obvious example of the second.
Law, once written,
created its own reality.
New histories of Roman law
should tell that story.
It happens to be one for
which we have some evidence.
Among the inventions
of the later tradition
is the so-called lex Aebutia,
the law that is credited
with introducing the formulary procedure.
Non-lawyers out there won't
care about the lex Aebutia,
but you'll just indulge
me, please, for a moment.
As I've stressed, the Romans did not know
the identity of the person
who proposed this law,
or the date, or a single
word of its language,
despite, on their representations,
its having affected a revolution
in legal and social life.
This is simply not plausible.
If the lex Aebutia existed,
the most plausible reason
for its light footprint in later memory
is that it changed nothing.
It was just forgettable.
This brings me to my second topic,
which is the science of
history, theirs and ours.
One thing the lex Aebutia did not do
is overturn some earlier world
in which civil procedure
operated so rigidly
that litigants who misspoke
a word of their script
lost their case.
I return now to that quotation
from Gaius about the trees.
This model of archaic laws
delivered to us principally by Gaius,
but also by Jelius.
Modern legal historians
who are desperate for these
stupid anecdotes to be true
never tire of praising Gaius
as having had historical interests.
And therefore, since he was a historian,
he preserved for us,
we can believe his evidence
despite its being something like
our only knowledge of
pre-formulary procedure.
What reason do we think
Gaius had reliable sources
for this information?
None.
On the contrary, his claims
about early Roman law
sound exactly like other nonsense
put forward by antiquarians
in the second century BCE
as they speculated about how
different, how wildly crazy
were the lives of archaic
versions of themselves.
For example, to bring on some evidence
from another moment in my life,
we are told nearly the same
thing about the punctiliousness
of Roman ritual in respect of religion.
If a Roman got a gesture wrong,
or misspoke a word, or
lacked an ingredient,
or an errant noise was
made during the ritual,
you had to restart the whole
damn thing from the beginning.
The Romans even gave
this performance a name.
It was called an instauratio.
But this is a complete fabrication
of the antiquarian tradition.
It is virtually without
evidence from actual practice,
and even from Roman, from
norms, from extant lege sacri.
Among other things, in
these extant lege sacri,
we have inscribed rules
that regulate the substitution
of one ingredient for another.
So if you didn't have the ingredient,
you just use something else.
We know formulae, which
are again preserved,
that you could utter by way of declaring
that an error in performance
was without ritual significance.
If something went wrong, you just said,
"Let it," you use the
third person imperative,
"Let it be held to have
been performed correctly,"
and you just went on with your life.
And so on.
Punctiliousness of this kind
in which you then redid
the whole expensive ritual
was something that one
attributed to one's ancestors
by way of imagining an
earlier age of rectitude.
But we decline to admit this
because we have our own longing,
in many ways, memetic of theirs,
to know a world when men were men
and Roman culture was pure.
Another comparandum
exists in Pliny's history
of Roman portraiture.
Just by way of, I mean,
you could really go on for a long time
about silly things Romans say
about earlier versions
of themselves, right?
What I call Pliny's spinal tap
theory of Roman art, right?
This is a joke about
the little Stonehenge that
appears in spinal tap, right?
'Cause according to Pliny,
early Roman portrait statues
were about a meter tall.
Now, it's not entirely clear
how Pliny imagines these
statues to have functioned.
Were early Romans very short,
and these were just
naturalistic representations?
(audience laughs)
Were statue bases very tall?
Instead of situating this
passage alongside others
in which Antonine Romans speculate about
the smallness or meanness
or so on of early crafts,
and instead of just
bursting with laughter,
one finds an amazing number of claims
that Pliny probably found
this (speaking Latin),
who might well have known people
who reported on this statuary via autopsy,
that said we've just generated this way
of insisting that their
knowledge must be true
because it's the kind of
thing we would like to know.
Finally, let me say, as
regards the Roman state,
so my final topic.
As regards the Roman state
in the second century BCE,
it's not simply that written documents
start to survive in great
number after Hannibalic War.
So do something like
contemporary literary accounts
about the production of further documents
that do not survive.
As it happens, virtually
the same pattern holds
for decrees of the Roman Senate.
This is not accidental.
And in that case too,
I suggest that the pattern
of surviving evidence,
of inscribed evidence,
maps the history of the production
of written senatorial decrees
more or less precisely.
This pattern could
issue from many factors,
some of which are not mutually exclusive.
That is to say, the pattern in our data
is not likely to have a single cause.
But two significant patterns
in the content of this
material are worthy of remark.
One, a great deal of the extant material
arises through the recourse of foreigners
to the Roman Senate
as a forum for dispute resolution.
This process clearly impelled
the development of procedural
means to conduct hearings
in what we might call
a rationalized fashion,
as well as the development
of documentary means
to represent those
hearings and their outcomes
in a distinct social elect
and on distinct medium.
This is, as it were, a corollary
to a pattern I mentioned earlier,
which is the one kind of document
that the Romans may have written
before the Hannibalic War
are treaties, because there
was a foreign counterparty.
So it was the foreign counterparty
that generated the need
to produce this thing
in a permanent form.
Second, the Senate is not suddenly visible
in foreign affairs,
which is to say, the
affairs between states.
It is also suddenly visible
guiding the conduct of magistrates.
What is more, this pattern,
the sudden interference of the Senate
in what particular senators were doing,
finds a correlate in data
provided by literary sources
with a kind of claim to veracity
regarding recourse of
members of the Roman elite
to the people, namely, to
legislative assemblies,
to trump the success of
rivals within the Senate.
In other words, Senate and Comitium,
to use a Fergus Miller-like phrase,
senate and Comitium are
quite suddenly on record,
frantically busy on record,
directing the activities
of elected officials
via legislative instruments.
Although they appear in narrative
as competing sources of authority
adduced by rivals in any given contest,
I think the activities
of Senate and Comitium
should in fact be understood
as mutually constitutive.
They rise to prominence as
competing sources of law
because the nature of domestic
elite political competition
was rapidly changing.
In part, of course,
in response to the changing
conditions of empire.
It lay in the nature of elite competition
that neither institution
was allowed a monopoly.
The recourse of one person, or group,
or faction to the Senate
provoked their rivals to turn
to the people, and vice versa.
But there is another level
in which competition,
in this case, competition
between sources of law,
both constitutes a space
and monopolizes it.
The performance of contestation
operates so as to convey the impression,
by virtue of its noise and nature,
that it exhausts and
covers the full terrain
of plausible positions.
The performance of competition
among sources of law
thus work to exclude voices and issues
not allowed into their staged cacophony.
In short, when properly staged,
competition among the elite
assists in sustaining
the elite as a whole,
as an elite.
Turning to the Senate and Comitium,
I suggested a moment ago
that neither obtained a monopoly
as a source of law in this period.
Instead, you might say
duopoly was the dominant form of monopoly
in second century Rome.
But a second order effect
of conducting and
constraining elite competition
through legislative enactment
was an intense and sudden
deridification of politics.
At Rome under the empire,
there was a long period
in which the empire
could be described as the
product of elite competition
rather than an end in itself.
In the language of Sallust,
which was echoed by Augustine
and affirmed by Machiavelli,
the virtue of the elite was expressed
in a desire to dominate.
And the project of empire
issued from a compromise
whereby the desire to dominate
was directed not at the masses at Rome,
but outward to enemies
further and further afield.
In consequence, a notable feature
of Roman republican politics
was that competition among the
elite for prestige and office
took place, to a very large
degree, outside of Rome.
It would not be wholly wrong to say that
for a very long time,
Roman foreign affairs
were an epiphenomenon
of domestic politics.
In the aftermath of the Third Punic War,
and increasingly across
the second century BCE,
the diversity and size of the empire
affected an inversion in these priorities.
It was Toynbee's argument
that the Hannibalic War was
decisive in this transformation.
The substance of any
given debate to one side,
the effects of this are visible
in the sudden subordination of priorities
in the give and take of politics
to the demand of collective constituencies
for predictable institutional operations,
in the light of vernacular understandings
of what we might term second
order or public goods.
Not only did magistrates have henceforth
to be constrained in
their conduct vis-a-vis,
conduct of politics vis-a-vis one another,
but one could simply no longer assume
a homology between the aggregated desires
of individual members of
the elite for eminence
and the larger needs of the state.
Magistrates had to be controlled.
Those controls are expressed
in the use of statute
to instruct magistrates in office,
and the passage of statutes
on magisterial malfeasance
that gave outsiders
access to Roman tribunals
at the very end of the century,
in the placing of geographic constraints
on magisterial action,
which amounted to an incipient project
of mapping and
territorializing the empire.
So let me now just,
let me conclude by
gesturing at three contexts
by way of provoking some conversation,
gesturing at contexts
that should be integrated
with the story I've tried to tell.
The first of this is historiography
of the First Punic War.
I think it seems pretty clear
that knowledge of the First Punic War
was shaky and contestable already
in the generation of Fabius Pictor.
Frankly, I think it's pretty clear
that the Romans themselves
knew nearly nothing about
what happened in the First Punic War,
and this would not be possible
if the state were generating
loads of written documents
in that era.
That said, to return to
a phrase I used earlier,
the performance of
contestation in historiography
had similar effects to those
that I describe in politics.
The fact that people
were disputing over facts
made it appear that the disputants
were arguing about something
that was at least potentially knowable.
Regarding the change from the
third century to the second,
I observed as well that
whatever the, sorry,
I want to observe that whatever
the Roman government did
in the earlier period,
whatever the Roman government
did in the third century,
it revisited those processes
later in the second
when, on my claim, the Romans
started to use writing.
Well, this is, well, I'll tell it.
How, this is not the,
actually, I won't go
back to the blank slide.
But how else are we to explain the fact
that the Romans wrote a law
on jurisdiction for Sicily
only in the year 132,
109 years after they
made Sicily a province?
Or in this case, right?
How are we,
this is an inscription from Aquileia
on the occasion of a
supplementary deduction,
the settling there of a
supplementary group of colonists
in the year 169.
"Titus Annius Luscus, son
of Titus, the triumvir.
He provided for the
construction of this temple
and dedicated it.
He composed and delivered laws,
and three times he
enrolled in the Senate."
So why is it only in 169 BC
on the occasion of a
supplementary deduction
that Aquileia received laws?
And of course, there's the
very interesting problem
that on its own account,
Rome only began to write poetry in 240
and history a generation later.
And each of these early
endeavors was in Greek.
Rome's first taking up in writing,
which is to say its late, late,
late taking up of writing,
was nevertheless felt
so frontal an assault
on aristocratic prestige
that Roman literature
had initially to deny
its own existence.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- And then thank you
very much, Clifford Ando,
for a marvelous talk.
We'll continue for about 20 more minutes,
so not past half past the hour.
Well, not much past, we'll say.
So we'll go over 20 minutes til 6:30
to give plenty of time
for questioning here.
And it's my inclination
to go ahead and let
you feel the questions,
if you don't mind.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much,
that was so (faintly speaking).
- [Noel] Excuse me, can
you just the pass the mic
or use the mics in the front?
- Oh, yeah, sorry.
- [Noel] Otherwise, we're not gonna hear.
Just pass it.
I can pass the mic up. (faintly speaking)
Just turn it on.
- [Audience Member] Oh, is it, is it on?
Is it on, no.
- [Noel] It was on.
- [Audience Member] Yes,
okay, thank you very much.
I was wondering, since
you ended with literature,
that was sort of where my mind was going
as you were sort of bringing up your talk.
And as you're so focused
on the way in which,
I guess, late republican and
early imperial historiography
is dedicated to sort
of creating the Roman,
and creating this legal
past for the Romans,
do you see, I guess,
these early kind of Latin texts
that are arising around the time
that you're theorizing
written law to be coming in?
Like Ennius' "Annales,"
like Naevius' "Punica,"
like those sorts of, Cato's "Origines,"
are you seeing the development
of Latin literature
and particularly this historiographical
ideological literature
as being connected to the legal
project that you are seeing,
if I understood you correctly?
- Yeah, now I'm gonna give
only a partial answer.
I'm not sure I'm competent.
And plus, there are people in the room
who are vastly more competent
than I to answer that.
So one quick answer.
I made these gestures at the end
in part because I had some
conversation with friends
about this paper.
I, you know, I showed it
to some Italian friends.
I sent it off to Jim Zetzel.
Said, "Jim, is this dumb?"
Jim, who really wants to
believe in Aelius' "Tripartita."
And because I have such
great respect for Jim Zetzel
that I said, "Yeah, maybe Sextus Aelius
had a copy of the Twelve Tables."
I tried also to make it
clear I don't believe that,
but Jim does.
And Jim really knows the
Republic and I do not.
So, I mean, I suppose I kind of believe
they have to be connected, right?
And it has something to do with,
it must have something to
do with, as you term it,
something like aristocratic prestige.
What I will say,
I could try to give a longer answer,
but let me just gesture to kind of
a way of thinking about the problem,
that there is a kind of
literature out there in the world,
a fun literature, a diverse literature,
'cause it comes from many
disciplinary viewpoints,
on the origins of writing
and the connection between writing
and certain kinds of
institutions of social authority
or between governmental knowledge.
So everything from Jack
Goody to Wang Haicheng.
Really great stuff.
I know of no comparable literature,
I know of no comparable
comparative literature
on a number of populations,
culture, civilizations,
whatever term you want to use,
that we can name that deliberately
did not take up writing,
that were surrounded by populations
that used writing and did not.
So one could think about the,
one could think about the, you know,
the early Persian tradition, right?
And the declining, in particular,
to write down the "Avesta."
But the simple non-use of writing
for recording in Persian, in particular,
until this extraordinarily
late moment, right?
You can think about the
very late introduction
of technologies of literacy
into the Sanskrit tradition,
which is very old,
but not nearly as old,
so far as one can tell,
as the Sanskrit tradition itself.
And you could say Rome.
And so there are at least
three cases that come to mind,
but there must be others out there
in which these cultures exist
surrounded by other
people who use writing,
and they insist on not writing.
And, you know, the
co-occurrence, you said,
you know, of the use of the
technologies of literacy
for governmental knowledge,
and then for these other forms of,
I don't know, cultural production,
for lack of a better word.
There must be,
there must be at least one
story to tell about them
that brings all those together.
I said that at the end
in the hopes, really,
that somebody else would
do that writing for me.
I don't have a great answer.
Thank you.
Sure.
- [Audience Member] Hello.
Thank you so much, this
is really so fascinating.
My question is about how we slot,
or how you see Roman law operating
before you see writing coming into it.
And sort of related to that,
whether one of the reasons why
we don't see anything really
cited before the Hannibalic War
is something to do with
what happens in that war
and the sort of massive loss of life
that our sources suggest
happened through that,
and whether there was some sort of
loss of knowledge, perhaps,
and of that oral tradition.
- So I can say something about
the first part of your question.
How did Roman law function
before the Hannibalic War?
And it would just be a total guess,
be my guess as opposed
to someone else's guess.
And I suppose I could riff
on this kind of question of,
you know, like trauma, violence,
destruction of property,
blah, blah, blah, you know.
Although I will say that, I mean,
to make a joke about other people
who write about this sort of stuff,
i.e., obviously Walter Scheidel,
what we don't see in Rome
is a massive destruction of property
which then issues in a 25 year period
after the Hannibalic War,
when all of a sudden every, you know,
like property regimes in Rome
are just vastly more
egalitarian because of,
you know, it's like the elite
stranglehold on ownership
was somehow broken,
so the Hannibalic War,
there are, to be more serious,
there are areas of Roman
life after the Hannibalic War
which do not seem to reflect
massive social trauma.
I mean, there are obviously areas that do.
I assume that Roman law
before the formulary system
used something like a formulary system.
That is to say, and by
that, what I mean is that
what happens in a formulary system,
there is ways you could modify this,
but what happens in the
formulary system is,
you know, the two litigants
show up in front of the
person in authority,
in the later case, in the
classical system, a magistrate,
who has the right to speak the law,
who's allowed to (speaking Latin),
and they tell their story, right?
And they say all sorts of
crazy bullshit, you know,
about, you know, "My neighbor's
trees fell into my yard."
And then they throw another
thing like, you know,
"He's crazy, he also
does it with his trash.
His dog barks all night, I can't sleep."
They throw out all sorts of stuff
as people do when they
narrate their own problems.
And when the magistrate produces a formula
in classical Roman law,
he produces a decision tree
in which he narrows
down the entire dispute
to a very complicated, long
sentence in which he says,
"If this, then why?"
And then there can be a
cascading set of decisions,
like if this, but if there's
an exception, go here, and on.
It looks like a tree, right?
And in which both a law,
a norm is brought to bear on the problem
and the case is re-narrated
so that only the salient
facts are mentioned.
And the job of the judge is
to decide which the facts go
toggle A, toggle B.
And I sort of assume that
instead of this silly business
in which there was only
five actions in Roman law,
and you had, you know, no matter
what your dispute was over,
you had to say trees,
then in fact, much of what happened before
is exactly what happens
in the formulary system.
You came up, the two litigants
described their problem,
and somebody,
and you know, what might've
been different, frankly,
is the existence of lay judges.
Or it could be that
before the lex Aebutia,
it was all handled by pontiffs,
and later it was handled by magistrates,
except that we know
that there were praetors
who handled jurisdiction
before the lex Aebutia.
So I just, I mean,
and it's for the reason that we think
we have knowledge of praetors
with jurisdiction before
that I suspect that law pre-lex Aebutia
probably looked something
like the formulary system.
I mean, despite the,
historians of Roman law loved to insist
in a kind of really profound way
on the difference between
the cognitio procedure
and formulary procedure.
And then if you actually look at
the actual conduct of cognitio procedure,
it looks an awful lot
like formulary procedure.
I mean, why the Romans were insistent
is an ideological matter.
But that, again, I think
that something like
the technologies of procedures
of elitum, the very few,
and some of them, I mean, now
I'm gonna say one last thing,
and then I swear I'll shut up.
Some of the aspects of
this procedure quite,
I'm gonna step aside from the whole issue
of the stupid pontiffs and
ritual punctiliousness.
A lot of aspects of their procedure
are probably overdetermined
by the fact that
there were no mechanisms of state power
that could compel somebody
to participate in civil litigation, right?
Right?
So if you wanted to sue your neighbor
and he refused to show up,
you're basically screwed.
And the Romans developed
mechanisms legally,
but not instrumentally.
There was never a police officer.
But there were legal means
you could bring to bear eventually
to force your neighbor to
actually show up in court.
But for a long time, these
things did not exist.
The Romans clearly date the
introduction of these things
extremely late.
So for a long time, you had the,
if a plaintiff filed a lawsuit,
the defendant had to be
persuaded to show up.
And there is a plausible case to be made
that one of the things that,
one of the reasons why Roman procedure
looks the way it does
is because you had to give the defendant,
you had to give the
defendant enough confidence
that he'd be willing to show up at all.
I could go on,
but I think that aspect is
probably much more interesting,
and probably also that
that kind of interpretation
should be brought to bear,
because it's a kind of real condition
that we know something about,
rather than this kind of
like mythological nonsense.
- [Audience Member] Thank you so much
for the fascinating talk.
And I'm very fascinated
by this concept of like
myth histories that you talked about,
and this kind of legal history
in constructing a Roman identity,
especially in relation
to outside foreign forces
that they're now coming into contact with
in the second century BCE.
And I was wondering if
you could talk more about
who specifically do you think
the Romans are talking to
when developing these laws?
And also what kind of
dialogues and messages
do you think that they
are trying to send out
to, like, these other foreign,
these foreign nations?
- Okay.
It's about legislation,
somewhat harder, but I will say,
let me just say a word, digress to,
step aside to the other
body of evidence I cited
that one could take up,
which is decrees of the Senate.
Actually, the decrees of the Senate
are an interesting thing to cite
in respect of legal procedure, right?
If you look at decree,
the early decrees of
the Senate that we have
almost always concern
something like foreign affairs.
It so happens that, of course,
many of them are epigraphically
preserved in Greek
in the east.
And interestingly, when
I said something like,
they developed this kind of
rationalized means for
representing adversarial speech,
they, you know,
you could imagine them
looking like two litigants
coming from the court, right?
So a senatus consultum very
rapidly develops this mechanism
for saying, you know,
these people came before us,
so-and-so, you know,
concerning the matter at hand said this,
so-and-so concerning the
matter at hand said that,
concerning the matter
which was immediately prior discussed,
blah, blah, and it goes on.
And there's all these markers.
And the speech of the
litigants is always paraphrased
in a way that makes them
appear to have spoken remarkably on point.
But that's also rationalized
in the sense that,
so that again, all the
chaff about, you know,
all the things that you might
have imagined that a Greek,
I'm supposed to stand in
front of the microphone.
All the chaff,
all the stuff that you can
imagine a Greek orator saying,
like, "Oh, it's so wonderful
to be before this most
distinguished body,"
and you know, blah, blah, blah.
And you know, "I come here
mindful of the extraordinarily
long history of relations
between your city and mine,
and the fact that," you
know, blah, blah, blah,
"we both worship Aphrodite,"
and all this other crap.
None of that is in the represented speech,
paraphrased speech in
the senatus consulta.
If you look at a senatus consulta,
somebody came and said,
"Please allow me to cite the
facts relevant to," you know,
"my claim in respect of the
ownership of (speaking Latin)
And on, on, on, on, on, on, on, on.
So they, you can see there something like
the technology of memory that might have,
a technology of memory that looks,
must be homeomorphic with the kind of,
with what a magistrate was doing
when people brought speech before a court.
So the senatus consultum
develops in a way,
in a kind of interesting way, right?
So that where the technology
of the letter, right,
that goes back from
the magistrate sends back to the thing
essentially repeats in a kind of
very different form of summary.
The content of whatever thing, you know,
the ambassador from Chicago
brought to New Haven.
The senatus consultum,
which has to render a
decision on the matter,
gives an extremely different
summary, which isn't,
and it is, I think, the,
it is, I think, the arrival of foreigners
that impelled the creation
of this technology.
I mean, there is no particular reason
to think that before that moment,
the Romans had a particular
set of mechanisms
for representing adversarial
speech in a written document.
So that would be one answer.
You know, about legislation,
I think it's much harder to tell.
It is noteworthy that the story
the Romans themselves tell
about writing legislation
is that they wandered
out to look for models
about how to write it up.
And that may be itself a version
of one of these kinds
of doublets I suggest.
I should add,
I know why this thought
occurred to me just now,
that, you know, the kind
of picture I'm presenting,
which is a picture of
one kind about, you know,
what I take to have been a
fairly massive set of changes
that I think probably did take place
at the start of the second century
in consequence of the Hannibalic War.
You know, the Romans did tell a story
about certain kinds of social revolutions
that took place as a
result of the opening up,
especially of wars in the east, you know.
And I wouldn't discount that.
I'm sure that in a
variety of different ways,
both as something like their relationship
to a new form of encounter
with cultures of writing,
but also in respect of
something like political economy
as a result of the importation of wealth,
that some of their historiography
about change in the second
century is surely accurate.
Not everything the Romans say
about their own past is dumb.
That would be a takeaway point there.
That's not a great
answer for your question.
I hadn't thought about that aspect of it.
- [Noel] One more question,
(speaking faintly).
One more question, anybody?
- [Audience Member] Yeah.
Actually, this might be a good follow on
to just your last point just there.
And I'm wondering sort of
outside of the realm of civil
procedure and statute law,
what we can discern, or you
think we can be discerned
just about sort of constitutional order
in the middle Republic, early Republic,
I mean, and whether this sort of,
which is often unwritten, anyway.
I mean, very little of the
fragments of the Twelve Tables
even have to do with kind
of constitutional law.
But from some of the historiography,
maybe from Pictor, whom you
mentioned, for instance,
we get a sense of, you
know, consul offices,
constitutional offices and et cetera.
So yeah, so I'm wondering if that,
the constitutional law, you think,
what Romans had to say about
their own constitutional order
might be something about which we have
some more ability to discern
outside of the realms of
civil procedure and statute.
But just curious, your comments on that?
- I'll make.
I was about to make some promise,
like I'll make two quick replies.
I'm not very good at that, but I'll, so...
Two things that seem to be
true about the Romans before.
So there is one area of public law where
I think it was Peter Brunt insisted
the Romans might have had real knowledge.
In a moment when Peter Brunt,
I can't find the passage,
but I think Brunt said somewhere
that he doesn't believe the Romans
actually knew anything
about their own past,
except possibly, he offers, I
think, in the same paragraph,
two possibilities.
One, that they remembered something about
big grants of citizenship,
because it was kinda like a thing
for the state to all of a
sudden admit new people.
I actually don't believe that.
But that the history of the
expansion of the tribal system,
that they may have had
some sense, right, of,
because of the materiality
of the extension
of the tribal system,
it did actually, right,
they may have, it was easy to guess
in what order the tribes were added.
Even if you didn't have
a narrative to tell you,
it would be easy to guess in what sort of,
make a guess what order
the tribes were added
and blah, blah, so that's one thing.
I should mention that
in the wider context of
what we're talking about.
Then there's about public law.
I mean, two things that do seem to be true
about Roman public law,
which you can guess on the basis of things
that we might think we might know,
are these Roman systems,
something like republican principles
of power relations among magistrates.
That one, you can protect
yourself from errant magistrates
by having them always be in even numbers.
And that is a kind of principle
that they widely observe.
So that's a feature of Roman public law
that I think was probably
true before, yeah.
And then it is noteworthy, I think,
that a kind of interesting
number of Latin abstractions
that derive from comparatives
appear in the language
of government, right?
Not simply maiestas, but
magisterium, ministerium,
and all that.
I mean, I don't know of
any other domain of Latin
in which there's so many
abstractions from comparatives
as government.
And I think this,
I think a lot of what the,
a lot of how they organize
something like public law,
which is to say moments of
dispute between magistrates,
which is when something
would have to be settled,
had to do with like two consuls facing off
or having two people argue,
and then somebody saying, "Well,
somebody's more important,
somebody's less important."
And that was it.
And you know, there's a really, I mean,
this is, I guess, part of what, I mean,
we might talk about with Seth tomorrow.
I might be taken to task.
But if you look at something like
Roman administration of Italy before 200,
the demands of Roman administration
for something like a
state knowledge apparatus
were astonishingly tiny.
Just astonishingly tiny.
I mean, you know, there was,
I mean, if you name something
that might actually have existed
as opposed to stuff for which
we have virtually no evidence,
the formula togatorum, right?
They didn't tax all these allies.
You didn't need to keep
records of property
or their riches or whatever.
All the kind of later
stuff, all the, right,
the form of later governmental knowledge,
the application of the
census, of all things.
I mean, the census with
its extraordinary ideology
as an instrument for assessing
who is a citizen and not.
The moment when you start
applying the census to foreigners
is an extraordinary ideological moment.
But it has a minor thing to do
with the fiscal demands of the state
and the way in which we're
now taxing people, right?
But before, you know, before some date,
the Roman demands on subjects
of Rome, especially in Italy,
were amazingly primitive.
And I think, I mean, by primitive,
I mean their,
the knowledge needs of these
processes were incredibly few.
I mean that's, to come back to public law.
I mean, their later public
documents of the state
which are co-related to functions, right?
In general, in spite of Andrew Riggsby,
the Roman state didn't go
nuts for writing shit down
unless it needed the knowledge,
or unless having the knowledge
had some really symbolic relationship
to an important function of government,
regardless of whether
it was actually used.
But the Roman state in the
third century, what knowledge,
knowledge was not,
knowledge was not an instrument of power.
I think in the, you know,
in the early one state.
Now Seth doesn't believe me at all.
(audience laughs)
Now I've really, I tried
in writing the paper.
I knew, particularly, you know,
particularly with Chris being
here, and, you know, and Seth,
I really didn't wanna say something stupid
about early republican Latin,
or, for that matter, about
the Roman state before 200.
But now I've gone and done it, so...
(audience laughs)
- So you can see the
conversation's not over,
as has been alluded to a thousand times.
We'll continue tomorrow
morning, maybe at 9:00 AM,
in Phelps Hall, 401.
And we have three distinguished
speakers in our company,
among whom is Seth Bernard.
He's been alluded to and pointed at,
mentioned a number of times.
(audience laughs)
A major expert in republican Roman history
who's joining us from the
University of Toronto.
And we also have Emily Hurt,
who is joining us from John
Cabot University in Rome
as a recent PhD of this program,
but also has tremendous knowledge
of the Republican period.
And finally, Rafail Zoulis,
current graduate student
who's studying Roman law.
More in the imperial period,
but I think has lots to contribute, too.
All these people will comment on
and then discuss the
paper with Professor Ando.
Please join us, if you will.
And in the meantime, though,
I had promised riches.
We haven't seen that
riches were delivered.
The good thing about riches
is they pay dividends
in the form of food and drink.
We can go over to the Union League
and the above, the second
story party room, as it were,
and continue the conversation
over some nice nibbles and drinks.
But first, let's give our
speaker a round of applause.
(audience applauds)
(peaceful music)